foreign
put up a picture
this is in response to two episodes ago
we did an episode called clutter core oh
yeah Danny put together this beautiful
video on Tick Tock and Instagram we put
up everywhere within the first day it
was approaching half a million views
across all the platforms and all these
people are outraged at what I said
okay and so I want to be really clear I
think the reason people are outraged
because it's a one minute clip out of a
much larger conversation thankfully it
brought a lot of people into the
conversation when I showed this picture
that's on your screen right now here's
what I said
this is not a design Trend this is a
mental illness if you just listen to the
audio version this is a picture of
clutter core it's just a woman sitting
among a bunch of clutter it is a picture
of hoarding
and people say well how dare you say
this is a mental illness why do you
think that it's a mental illness I said
well it's not about my opinion my
opinion doesn't matter at all
but
hoarding has been considered a mental
illness
for decades now and that's not according
to me that's according to the Mayo
Clinic to NHS to the Cleveland Clinic
and several other experts now I'm not
going to just defer to The Experts for
everything but I also want to be clear
about something I don't think of mental
illness is a Bad Thing hoarding whether
you're a stage one hoarder stage three
hoarder stage five hoarder Ryan and I
were stage two three hoarders back in
the day yeah
yeah crazy to think that anyway because
I didn't feel like order right now yeah
and so hoarding
is uh according to many experts on the
OCD Spectrum I'm a person who has OCD
has been diagnosed with OCD has had it
since I was about age six and it doesn't
manifest in some of the ways where you
have to turn door knobs a bunch of times
but I do a lot of things that are
ocds guy count steps I count uh stairs I
I do a lot of counting of things and I
obsess a lot I'm much more obsessive
than I am compulsive and so that is
considered to be a mental illness and
that's not to say that I think it's a
bad thing
this is a problem clutter core is a
problem merely because
it is reframing something that is
getting in the way and saying that it is
a good thing it's holding on to the
things that make us miserable
and saying this
is beneficial to you now if you actually
enjoy whatever things you have in your
space I don't want you to get rid of any
of it I'm not in the business of trying
to convince you of anything
the problem that we have is when we say
hey I have this problem instead of
looking at the problem addressing the
problem wondering the why behind that
problem the why behind the clinging I'm
going to proudly display my clinging
pretend it is not a problem and that's
when we get confused so no I don't think
it's a I don't think it's a bad thing
but I think that if it gets in the way
telling yourself a story that it doesn't
get in the way doesn't keep it from
getting in the way yeah
all right Angels Advocate question
if having a mental illness is not a bad
thing
and if let's say hoarding is a mental
illness
what does it add to the conversation to
label it as such a good question we had
a question earlier about ADHD and the
thing I didn't have the time to say in
the moment we can talk about it now is
you're right adding a label to a thing
can be helpful
because it limits it right and it allows
you to talk about it right and so labels
everything is a label I'm drinking from
this coffee mug that's a label right but
as soon as you label something
it also puts it in a box that you cease
to see it Anthony Demello says as soon
as you you give the bird a name you
cease to see it right and so you're
right in in the respect that if I label
it a mental illness maybe we actually
cease to see it but being that we're on
a podcast
I want to talk about things the way they
are I don't want to pull any punches and
I don't want to soften it in a way that
pretends that it isn't I don't I don't
want to say that it's not a mental
illness and that it's okay for you to
hold on to all the stuff that is making
you miserable it's fine with me if you
do I don't care if you do right I I got
you on that like I'm not I'm not
thinking that you should be pretentious
in PC but like even when you say I'm not
going to put any punches is it a punch
then because you're like like on one end
it sounds like hey like having a mental
illness is not a bad thing hey man if
that's what you're doing if that's a
mental illness now look it's okay if
that's what you want to do but it's a
mental illness like it sounds like it's
a little bit of both it sounds like
there's something that calling it a
mental illness
adding to the discussion and I'm trying
to get at what that is I think it is
Josh trying to shake the listener a
little bit or the viewer
um appeal says it doesn't really matter
but at the same time it's pathetic
if it doesn't matter it can't be
pathetic it's just meaningless but
anyway yeah no I mean I mean everything
first off um
you know there's a there's a lot of uh I
don't know oxymoronic things about you
know nothing is or is is only is or is
only isn't
like it isn't it isn't at the same time
so mental disorder or mental illness I
should say
um it's not a bad thing it's not a good
thing
um I think when Josh says mental
disorder what it does is it makes the
the whoever you know the viewer
um look at that and say oh wow like
mental disorder is something that is
going on in the mind that if we don't
get control of it will be out of control
and our life will be uh worse off if
that disorder gets out of out of hand so
um yeah I mean mental disorders never
a positive thing it's certainly
um is a pejorative statement but you
know Josh isn't trying to shame anyone
yeah I disagree it's not pejorative at
all it's a statement
my father was schizophrenic he had a
mental illness I'm not saying that
pejoratively yeah I'm stating it as a
matter of fact
hoarding is a mental illness now we can
pretend that it's not we can celebrate
hoarding
but it's still a mental illness yeah and
until we understand that consumerism so
am I pulling punches no I'm not going to
pull punch am I punching yes I'm
punching at consumerism consumerism is
the ideology that buying things is going
to make you a whole happy person no it's
not our society
has become pathological we are a
mentally ill Society yeah we think that
we can consume our way to happiness life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
how's that working out for you it's
making you miserable and if you're
miserable keeping more stuff onto it
that is the definition of insanity it is
a mental illness it's a huge problem in
our society and I don't want to
sugarcoat it anymore if you're happy
with your stuff be happy with your stuff
but if the stuff is making you miserable
I wouldn't cling to it and celebrate it
and say look at me look how much stuff I
own oh by the way it's it's kind of
making me miserable yeah and that's
that's the challenge of highlight clip
culture which we are part of because
even in the the discussion on clutter
core you and I had a disagreement about
whether or not this is hoarding and I
was kind of making the case that maybe
it's a way of like uh transforming what
would otherwise be hoarding into a form
of creative expression and and even
during that segment you talked about how
like look if you find joy in it and
you're at peace with it and you're
getting all into the artistic component
of it then that's fine but but but
that's not what you're addressing and so
it's like but yeah you don't get that
part of the discussion where you're
acknowledging those sorts of things and
making those nuanced points when you say
let's let's find a good 30 second
component for engagement or whatever you
know and you know what's funny by the
way you said that you had like half a
million views on the first day it's so
fascinating
that a clip that made a lot of people
mad and say I'm angry with you I don't
like this show anymore
that it was like better for the show
than the stuff that people say they like
and it's just fascinating right we we
wonder why celebrity culture Isn't So
incentivized to manufacture controversy
because even though we complain about it
we give far more energy to the stuff
that we hate in the form of complaints
than we do due to the stuff we say we
love in the form of Celebration did you
enjoy this Standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free